reaction saturday
what's up you guys my name is the cherno
welcome back to another one of these
reaction saturdays
first of all yes finally got a haircut
isolation hair
is over you guys on twitter told me to
take a look at the ratchet and clank
rift apart announcement trailer
which is what we'll be looking at today
i haven't seen it before i think it's a
really cool thing to look at because
it's running on the playstation 5 and of
course last time we did these reactions
we took a look at the playstation 5
in general have them linked up there if
you haven't seen that so
i'm excited to take a look at the first
actual game i've seen running on a
playstation 5 i mean not counting the
unreal engine tech demo because that was
just a tech demo so
let's dive right into it and of course
i'll try and give you my thoughts
looking at this as a game engine
developer specifically
all right so immediately i just want to
pause this already
i this looks really nice i love games
that have this kind of aesthetic
it's not like they're not trying to be
specifically photorealistic
they're just trying to be i think like
nice looking if that's like a thing um
that i can use to describe this but
looking at this shot like to me
immediately it looks like some kind of
like just like an animated movie
right like the thing that really makes
this look good first of all
i think if we break this down kind of
frame by frame and i promise i won't do
this
throughout the whole video and a lot of
people get very upset when i talk too
much which is i don't know strange to me
because it's it's my you um
it's my reaction watching this guy watch
the original video if you want to watch
the original video
i'll have it linked down there by the
way but looking at this frame
the thing that i think makes this frame
look the best at the moment
is the depth of field like that
bokeh is absolutely butter
that's about a channel right there that
that is
it's so smooth like it honestly looks
like a not just like a camera
but like an expensive camera lens right
there i love the particles floating
around everywhere that definitely adds
to it as well
the particles are slightly out of focus
which is really cool the colors are
pretty standard the foreground
there's not too much going on going on
in the foreground in this shot i mean
everything is really nicely lit i love
this kind of area of specular
highlights over here everything is like
the animation's obviously quite fluid
and nice
but i think that looking at this frame
the thing that um
like gets me the most excited about this
or that that i think
looks the best here is just the way that
they've laid the
the foreground and background with the
blurriness with the depth of field
because that just makes the shot look so
cinematic and so much better
i'm assuming this is like a cutscene
rendered in real time of course
[Music]
particles everywhere that's a huge huge
deal
and by huge deal i mean to like for the
visual quality of the scene
nothing to do with like the playstation
5 or anything yeah
again like that they've they're kind of
they're taking a very cinematic approach
to this
having like what looks like a fairly
long focal length style camera here with
a
quite a blurry kind of background you
are right back
no way
okay lots of stuff going on in this shot
you can see that like not not uh not to
be
not to say that this looks bad or
anything but you can see that it does
look worse when they've
you know when they show more of the
background when they have those tight
shots in with like a 50mm
style lens or something like that and
then the blurry background it definitely
looks a lot higher quality with this
there's just a lot of stuff going on and
you can see that like the trees in the
background here if you really look
deep like i feel like there
there's probably some lighting missing
on them like i don't see much shading to
do with like shadows or occlusion or
anything like that
they look kind of flat to me the
foreground looks a lot better
and obviously like this is the ratchet
and clank aesthetic they're not trying
to be photorealistic i'm just trying to
look at it
from from kind of what i see when i look
at this frame
and the things that stand out to me
first of all it appears that the
dimensions are collapsing on one another
if we cannot get to it looks like
there's some kind of noise going on it's
hard to tell
it's got to be just youtube compression
i'm watching this at 4k but
you can see the youtube compression here
just just in the in the kind of out of
focus elements like over here
you can see it change frame to frame
which is kind of disappointing maybe
there's a vimeo version or something
high quality
right that looks really nice the metal
kind of reflection
i'm just trying to see if i can see
anything in the reflection you can see
they're kind of using that teal and
orange lighting as well
um here to try and make it look a little
bit
nicer um but it doesn't look like it's
reflecting anything else
anything like anything dynamically
height the ship
because like for example you can't see
um
can't see ratchet here in the actual
reflection
i mean we can't beat that so it's got a
like it's probably not doing any kind of
ray trace reflections there
they have found us ratchet
i might steer this thing ask nicely
there's a lot of detail going on here
which is really cool i imagine this
would be
like i don't know it's going to be quite
a fun game i think
like this this is and the thing is like
i just want to emphasize i know that i'm
kind of doing my reaction
i'm mostly focusing on the visuals and
i'm kind of scrutinizing them a little
bit but i
just want to emphasize that i'm looking
at this critically and i'm trying to
like assess this frame and everything i
see that kind of stands out to me
but obviously graphics do not make a
game
graphics are important for a game but
like photorealistic graphics for example
don't make a game necessarily better
unless that's what it's trying to do and
that's what it needs for the actual
delivery
of the experience this is clearly a fun
kind of cartoony game so looking at this
stuff and being like oh look it's not
reflecting the
it's not raytrace reflection that's not
the point at all i'm just pointing out
things i see so i just want to just a
little disclaimer because i'm enjoying
this and i
think that obviously this is not going
to stop me from playing the game
because it's missing a reflection or
whatever
yeah but i love the environment i
actually kind of i love this aesthetic
and i love the
um i just love the the feel of this you
know it's quite vibrant you can see the
sun spots here and like when the lights
kind of
bleeding through the environment itself
looks really really nice and nice
i love this kind of aesthetic
those kind of fluid explosions look nice
how do i steer this thing
let me just try and pause there it's
like around here
yeah look at that that looks kind of
cool
i wonder how they did all of this i
wonder if it's actually like a fluid
simulation or if it's just a pre-baked
kind of animation
look at that there's so much there's so
much like there's so many effects going
on visually which
like you know there's this kind of
portal over here there's a lens flare
that's being overlaid here there's like
all of these explosions and particles
just the particles everywhere the
general ambience for the environment is
really well done
so i think like the environmental the
environment artists here have done a
really good job at actually filling the
world with so much detail
which is going to be important and i
imagine that you know if i had to bring
this back to the playstation 5 i'd
probably say that the fact that the ps5
ssd is so fast means that they're able
to
have this much detail in the world
because it's kind of difficult to have
detail in the world when you're dealing
with such a
such a limited amount of like video ram
or
like cpu ram that you have to use but if
you have a whole ssd
and a whole library of assets to choose
from that are bundled with your game
then you can really create so much more
detail
in your world because you don't have to
worry about how much
actual data you can have in a frame
which i think is really beneficial
and really cool
the dimensions are weakening
considerably
i have to go back a little bit here and
look at what's actually going on in all
of this
all of these like panels here because
they look like um
um i thought they were moving but
they're just images
i thought that these kind of uh i guess
glass shards were reflecting or like
showing some kind of world
actually being dynamic and moving but it
looks like they're just images and
there's textures
[Music]
i just wanna like him jumping through
all of these wells here is making me
feel as if this is just a demo to be
like hey look we're a playstation five
we can load all these walls worlds at
once um but it is it is cool obviously
well it is certainly oh wow that reminds
me this kind of background the way it's
kind of almost um
it just looks hand drawn like a 2d kind
of hand-drawn uh
image it reminds me a lot of borderlands
and that aesthetic
really everywhere and i have to like i
haven't played many ratchet and
clank games before i think the last time
i played that was on like the
playstation 2
but um i don't know if this is the
aesthetic they go for these days but
it's
yeah it's really cool and obviously i
expect all of these kind of shadows and
everything you've seen these cliffs to
be completely like just statically baked
in a light map even though the
playstation 5 might be able to do some
cool things with that dynamically
there's just no need for it
this is cool
yeah the particles here are really cool
let's go back a little bit look at all
those particles flying around the fire
looks
pretty much real which makes me think
that it's just you know it is probably
somewhat real it's probably probably was
recorded like on a camera
and then you know uh used as just
just like a 2d animation that's pretty
common to do with visual effects fire
these days not that it necessarily has
to be like that
i just know that like battlefield 4 and
like a lot of the fire effects there
were done that way
um but the the particles yeah the
particles
are just look at these sparks everywhere
look at the
yeah this game just loves particles
which is really cool i love particles
i think particles are really cool look
at this but the thing
that's interesting about the particles
at least looking for from these shots is
that first of all
in general they have quite a bit of
motion blur in these action scenes which
is
you know great and then also you can see
that
it looks like the depth of field is
affecting the particles obviously these
particles up here
uh and like over here like some of them
are blurry because emotion blur some of
them it looks like they're just blurry
because they're out of focus
which is also really cool like if you
removed the particles from this scene
and you remove the depth of field from
this scene and you remove the motion
blur from this scene
this would probably look like a
playstation 3 game uh so
like the effects really bring this to
life and i just want to stress that the
reason for that is that they've got a
nice call they've got a nice aesthetic
for this game
right the aesthetic is simple the
aesthetic is not like
immense photorealistic detail and
because of that
that that this aesthetic is achievable
on lower end hardware
but the things that i'm seeing here that
i think might be
next-gen i hate using that term but the
things that i see here that could
potentially be next gen or things that
they maybe couldn't have done as much on
a playstation 4 or three
are probably just the particles and
maybe the quality of the blur
um that's probably been stepped up just
because there's just more processing
power available to compute that
but in general um yeah it'd be
interesting to look at this frame
without those effects because it would
look
i don't know you guys probably wouldn't
like it
ah look at the that's cool um
there was like a particle effect here
that warped the back like it warped the
image yeah
this you can see like it's it's creating
some kind of like refraction
it's on yeah there it is this is that's
really cool and that's probably
something that would
have been i mean i'm not going to say it
wouldn't have been achievable
on last gen or playstation 4 or whatever
it probably would have been but
like the the quality of it is
undoubtedly like
able to be higher as a result of
the higher processing power of the new
consoles
and like i mean computers can obviously
do this as well
i'm sure the xbox can dare i say um i
don't really care about the hardware
anything can do that but just the fact
that you know there's more processing
power available is just good
all right here we have some nice like
pbr material there's that teal and
orange kind of light again
um it's probably just part of their
aesthetic
doesn't look like he's reflecting any
actual
i don't remember him in clank but
reflecting any any actual
um uh environment stuff
really that much like dynamically
i'm just looking at i'm just looking at
all the environment
i would have expected him to clank more
when he hit that to be honest looks like
he
ratchet we are too late
ratchet
who
all right and that is ratchet and clank
rift apart
captured on playstation 5 as it says
here in the disclaimer
um yeah i hope you guys enjoyed
this uh my final thoughts on this
it looks cool um i think that the
environment the environment artists have
absolutely done a great job in in being
able to put so much detail into these
environments because that's not an easy
job and that's probably the most
time-consuming part of
creating this game i would say is
probably the environment
there's so much stuff going on here
which is really cool to see
the fact like i mean it looks like it
looks like
the maybe the sony executives came to
insomniac games and we're like hey guys
look our ssds are super fast we can
switch between
levels like that make a game that
focuses on
traveling between different rifts and
dimensions because that's gonna like
market our console really well
not to say that's a bad thing but i i
just i just feel like it's very
coincidental that as soon as the
playstation 5 has a very fast ssd that
can load levels very quickly
a game comes out loading levels very
quickly which could be something that
they've wanted to do for a while but
couldn't in which case
absolutely great job but it also could
be something of
um of just basically trying to promote
the playstation 5 more which
i'm not against i think that in general
like it looks like a absolutely
fantastic game
uh and obviously it really does show the
fact that the playstation 5 can
load data really quickly from disk
so yeah leave your thoughts in the
comment section below
and let me know if there's something
else that you want me to check out for
the next time i do reaction saturday not
sure if i'll do this
every single week but if something cool
comes up that you want me to check out
then i will absolutely do that so thank
you guys for watching
love you all goodbye
[Music]
you